اندلعت ليله الماضيه مواجهتهم بين
فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
مدينه نابلس الشماليه الضفه الغربيه
مشاهد قالت انها من الدلاع المواجهات على
مفرق بلده بيتا
وكانت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه اعلانات
استشهاد الشاب الذي اصيب امس الجمعه برصاص
اسرائيلي اطلق عليه من المسافه والسفر في
حواره جنوبيه نابلس
انها لفلسطين الاثنين حاول تقليص شاب من
قبضه الجندي الذي اطبق الخناقه عليه وسحبه
الى مكان اخر واطلق النار عليها وزعمت
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الشابه حول
سرقه سلاح الجندي وطعنه يقوم الجندي اطلاق
النار عليه
[موسيقى]
هذا واعربه الخارجيه الامريكيه عن قلقها
من استمرار العنف في الضفه الغربيه كما
اعرب الاتحاد الاوروبي عن بالغ قلقه مما
وصفه بتصاعد العوم في الضفه الغربيه بما
فيها القدس محتله
الاحتلال 10 الفلسطينيين خلال اثنتين
وسبعين ساعه يعكس استخدام قوى الامن
الاسرائيليه القوه المميته وهو ما يخالف
مبادئ القانون الدولي
منذ عام 2006 وطالب بالتعقيق في وقوع
الضحايا بين المدنيين وضمان المسائله